want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn do
you need a college education to be an
entrepreneur
enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be guided by your interests with
warren buffett is business school worth
it depends on the person that uh much
more than it depends on the school i
mean i wouldn't worry some people are
going to get a lot out of advanced
education and some people are going to
get very little and
i don't even think it's important that
every person go to college at all i mean
we have all kinds of jobs at
70 or so thousand a year 80 000 a year
that
college training is is is not abuse and
i i actually was not keen on going to
college
myself yeah my dad
uh kind of jollied me into it he could
get me to do anything but and if they'd
had an s.a.t test in those days he would
have taken the test for me
but i knew i could have a good time and
i liked investing and i didn't really
feel
i could read the books
you know it's a big commitment to take
four years and the cost involved and
maybe the loans involved and everything
i think
depending on
what your interests are in life
uh
i don't i don't think it's for everybody
i think it's for a lot of people but
there ought to be a reason you're going
and i didn't really see much reason rule
number two learn on your own with elon
musk first of all
you don't need college learning learn
stuff okay
everything is available basically for
free
you can learn anything you want for free
it is not a question of learning
um
there is
a value that colleges have which is like
you know seeing whether somebody's
is can somebody work hard at something
including a bunch of
sort of annoying homework assignments
and still do their homework assignments
uh and and kind of soldier through and
and get it done
you know that's
that's like
the main value of college and then also
you know if you you probably want to
hang around with a bunch of people your
own age for a while instead of going
right into the workforce
um
so i think colleges are basically for
fun and to prove you can do your chores
but they're not for learning rule number
three figure out what you want with gary
vaynerchuk if somebody actually thinks
they're an entrepreneur at 1516 and has
proved it she sells blowpops or she has
a website on shopify if you are truly an
entrepreneur
and
you are going to take debt
to go to college i will punch you in the
face and try to stop you
i couldn't believe in it less
if you want to work in this building at
boston consulting you better go to
something solid undergrad and you better
go ivy league business school because
you want to work at boston consulting
mckinsey or bain as you mentioned it
early i think you have to figure out
what you want in life and work backwards
i am
unbelievably down on the business of
education in america if you are trying
to do entrepreneurial things and or if
you know who i'm most scared of uh i'll
go to wisconsin or michigan or florida
you know those kind of schools and take
on debt and think i'm gonna have a good
job out of school those those great
schools kind of in the upper middle the
upper middle class of schools they're
getting suffocated there's only room for
harvard and stanford great jobs but
these unbelievably great schools if you
now if mommy and daddy pay for it
and you can go to the big game and ohio
state if you're michigan or vice versa
and play that whole life and you get
four years you get to have some fun you
get to mature a little bit get out of
the house cool
but only if you want a job a rod like if
you want a job how about if our audience
wants to get rich what's your advice to
them i think a lot of people will get
rich by having a job i think there's a
lot of people who are number sixes
who want to be number ones and they're
coming up with the uber of dry cleanings
and they're gonna lose and go into
depression and so i'm telling them hey
this entrepreneur thing that you think
is cool you think i'm cool it sucks
you're lonely it's all on you if you
lose it's a scarlet letter are you that
kid because if you went to horace mann
and then you went to
yale you might not be that person you
might be a great number six and so it's
awesome to do that and then go to
mckinsey and then become number six at
facebook or number six at a big company
and you will become rich but if you're
like me
and you're from the dirt and you know
and you've always known that like
sitting in a classroom isn't for you and
you've shown a nice snack for flipping
sneakers and things of that nature if
your parents are forcing you to go to
college because it makes them feel good
and you have to take on debt it's time
to stand up and have that conversation
rule number four learn from experience
with kevin o'leary i've come to a new
place in my understanding what works and
doesn't i also went through the
educational process i did an mba and
people ask me does that have anything to
do with success or failure i say no it
doesn't i don't remember a single thing
i learned there for the two years except
the people i met that that now are out
there in the world as bankers and
lawyers and whatever else they are and i
use them as my bit database of contacts
to help build my businesses
so i think that was important but
the classes that i forget completely
what it was about
i will say one thing though i've learned
something from what the europeans do
evan and listen to this in switzerland i
have a stepfather who swiss he lives in
geneva switzerland i've been going over
there for 40 years back and forth
take a company like nestle
they offer an internship program that
they call an apprentice program over
there it's it's almost like the
sorcerer's helper in a disney movie
in high school
if you think you like the food industry
maybe you know nestle's a global food
company they'll let you come in and work
on weekends and afternoons after school
to see what it's like in the real world
even though you're just a teenager
why are they doing that
they're trying to figure out
who is going to be the next asset for
their company that is going to be
someone who attaches themselves to the
business maybe long term
so they get to try you out you get to
try them out they pay you a small
stipend
but that's an apprenticeship what an
opportunity for you you're a teen
you're sitting in a meeting with a bunch
of managers you're absorbing all that
stuff
and you're learning why the hell don't
we do that in north america because
maybe one out of ten is the right person
but once you're indoctrinated if that's
the right word into the call it the
nestle program
you're a nestlet you're there they want
you you want them and a way your career
goes
i love it i think every company in north
america should take that program on and
and offer this opportunity to kids and
their teens and say look you want to see
what work is
you want to see what it's like get in
here but it also gives you a chance as
an entrepreneur to say i understand the
corporate structure and now i want to
try something a little different on my
own but i will have had that base of
information not only about what it's
like but that sector if you love the
food industry you're with the el supremo
and you're learning about it and then
one day you can split off and say hey
nestle i'm going to build this food
business you want to buy from me i have
to guess the 50 million that's the
program i like also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
rule number five finish college with
mark zuckerberg my question for you do
you think a bachelor's degree with your
experience with your uh your experience
with college and if you think a
bachelor's degree is a necessary key to
attaining success
ooh i am not your role model on this one
um
yeah absolutely
stay in school
uh look look real um
i think it helps i i loved i loved the
time that i spent in college i wish i
could have gotten more time i did not
choose to leave i just
happened to build facebook and it kind
of made me leave but if i had the
opportunity to
um to learn for two more years in
college college is this magical time
right where you get to explore different
interests and focus on different things
um and meet
great people and that is not something
that i would have wanted to have given
up and if i had could have
magically both done if i could have done
facebook in my senior year um i would
have done that or or after i left i
would have done that and i wish i could
have stayed in college but
and of course there's no doubt i mean
there's a lot of research
that shows that having a bachelor degree
absolutely does
help increase your job potential
your earnings potential all that so
yeah i mean look i mean it's kind of
crazy for you i'm not necessarily the
best spokesperson for this message but
like
unless there's a really really good
reason to leave college you really
should finish college
um you know and even me
i um
i'm going back to college to get i'm
going to get a degree this year
um harvard finally allowed me to come
back
um
and um
and i have to say you know
i think that this is probably going to
be the thing that my parents are most
proud of me for
so
um so look yes i i'm not the right
messenger but stay in school rule number
six invest with robert kiyosaki
the question is has school damaged you
and i'm not kidding about that has
school made you poor
and what has school done for you because
every time i get into these discussions
with these
i mean i was just i just did an
interview into japan and i'm fourth
generation japanese american and this
guy was a straight a student this guy
was the most the biggest
coward i ever made he was so terrified
of making mistakes
you know he was a straight a student or
whatever they do in japan and he was
just terrified and i kept saying what
are you afraid of he said well you know
i won't make a mistake you know and all
this
so the question again to you is this has
school damage you either by not going to
school
or did you do well in school does it
damage you
most of my friends dropped out of school
and they're they're multi-millionaires
you know if you look at some of the
greatest entrepreneurs in the world they
never finished school
you know a guy named um steven job steve
jobs
walt disney uh zuckerberg henry ford
branson
so again the question is we're going to
find out how school damage you but most
important what can you do about it like
i almost shot that poor guy in japan man
that guy
i mean he kept asking me the most stupid
questions i could not believe he says
but isn't investing risky i said yeah if
you're not smart rule number seven do
what fascinates you with steve jobs i
dropped out of reed college after the
first six months but then stayed around
as a drop in for another 18 months or so
before i really quit
so why'd i drop out
[Music]
it started before i was born
my biological mother was a young unwed
graduate student and she decided to put
me up for adoption
she felt very strongly that i should be
adopted by college graduates so
everything was all set for me to be
adopted at birth by a lawyer and his
wife
except that when i popped out they
decided at the last minute that they
really wanted a girl
so my parents who were on a waiting list
got a call in the middle of the night
asking we've got an unexpected baby boy
do you want him
they said of course
my biological mother found out later
that my mother had never graduated from
college and that my father had never
graduated from high school
she refused to sign the final adoption
papers
she only relented a few months later
when my parents promised that i would go
to college
this was the start
in my life
and 17 years later i did go to college
but i naively chose a college that was
almost as expensive as stanford
and all of my working-class parents
savings were being spent on my college
tuition
after six months i couldn't see the
value in it
i had no idea what i wanted to do with
my life and no idea how college was
going to help me figure it out
and here i was spending all the money my
parents had saved their entire life
so i decided to drop out and trust that
it would all work out okay
it was pretty scary at the time but
looking back it was one of the best
decisions i ever made
the minute i dropped out i could stop
taking the required classes that didn't
interest me
and begin dropping in on the ones that
looked far more interesting
it wasn't all romantic
i didn't have a dorm room so i slept on
the floor in friends rooms i returned
coke bottles for the five cent deposits
to buy food with
and i would walk the seven miles across
town every sunday night
to get one good meal a week at the hari
krishna temple
i loved it
and much of what i stumbled into by
following my curiosity and intuition
turned out to be priceless later on let
me give you one example reed college at
that time offered perhaps the best
calligraphy instruction in the country
throughout the campus every poster every
label on every drawer was beautifully
hand calligraphed
because i had dropped out and didn't
have to take the normal classes
i decided to take a calligraphy class to
learn how to do this
i learned about serif and sans serif
typefaces about varying the amount of
space between different letter
combinations about what makes great
typography great
it was beautiful historical artistically
subtle in a way that science can't
capture
and i found it fascinating
none of this had even a hope of any
practical application in my life but ten
years later when we were designing the
first macintosh computer it all came
back to me and we designed it all into
the mac it was the first computer with
beautiful typography if i had never
dropped in on that single course in
college the mac would have never had
multiple typefaces or proportionally
spaced fonts and since windows just
copied the mac it's likely that no
personal computer would have them
[Applause]
if i had never dropped out i would have
never dropped in on that calligraphy
class and personal computers might not
have the wonderful typography that they
do
of course it was impossible to connect
the dots looking forward when i was in
college but it was very very clear
looking backwards ten years later again
you can't connect the dots looking
forward you can only connect them
looking backwards
so you have to trust that the dots will
somehow connect in your future you have
to trust in something your gut destiny
life karma whatever
because believing that the dots will
connect down the road
will give you the confidence to follow
your heart
even when it leads you off the well-worn
path and that will make all the
difference rule number eight learn to
invest with tai lopez you live in the
modern world i highly suggest you ask
for your money back for your education
i'm talking about junior high high
school and yes a lot of college for most
people
i'm telling you i'm out here hiring
people out of the high school system the
college system i'm like bro what did you
learn you know nothing
i'm not saying that in a condescending
way i'm saying it in like a surprise
like
what
what
what are you learning
people can't do common sense stuff they
can't problem solve if the
solution isn't right there it's like
mcdonald's what do they program people
to do
okay they literally you've seen a
mcdonald's cash register what they have
to do they have to put the name
of the it's like big mac
they can't leave people to put the math
in
you can't have kids go okay big mac is
99 cents 99 cents no hold no no no
school system then produce people that
can do that
heck no you have to
label it
big mac okay
is that really healthy for people
no
because the brain is a little bit like
your muscles you
use it or lose it
what kind of math is being taught math
and even the kind of math that's being
taught is stuff that is only going to be
used by people who are engineers
what about applied math simple problem
solving that simple ratios simple
percentages
so you can figure out the general just i
got people come to do marketing for me
i'm like what's the ratio of the like to
view racial people like what the what's
that
oh
you don't have to be a mathematician you
can literally use a calculator to do
that but the school system get your
money back on the school system i'm
telling you
i read an article that said in some
states of the like the united states new
york
the average kid has 200 000
spent taxpayer dollars in public school
before they graduate high school two
hundred that quarter million dollars you
put that in a savings account or
investment account at eight percent
it'll double every nine years by the
time they retire you could have just
given them a million dollars cash the
average 60 year old in america retires
with under a hundred thousand dollars
you should have getting them gotten the
money back from the school system people
say oh but then what will people learn
to do what will people do between age
six and eighteen well i can think a lot
of things see school now has become
babysitting because parents have we live
a nuclear family you got to have the 9
to 5 job you got to have the kids do
something so ok i get that i was raised
by a single mom she needed school some
time to babysit me it's expensive
daycare
though well how about let kids run
around
how about that how about let kids learn
self-defense learn how to box 2000 years
ago greeks were teaching wrestling
you know because you get some strength
you learn how to overcome you learn how
to push through mental fortitude comes
from physical things now you got kids
they let them walk around the track
three times we can't figure out why
obesity has become a problem
how about teaching letting people play
musical instruments
how about letting people read
interesting books
my high school i remember a eighth ninth
grade or whatever they made us read
siddhartha
really that's a way
to encourage people to want to read book
no wonder i read a book a day people are
like that's impossible yeah well you
went through the school system the
average person who goes through high
school and college doesn't read a
non-fiction book again for over i think
one to three years i read i don't know
if that statistic's true but i believe
it i think that's generous
get your money back
let kids read all day in school
you learn more and not siddhartha not
some
i don't know who picks the books
but i can pick books that'll blow kids
mind they'll want to read let people
elon musk told me i was at the golden
globes and i asked elon musk what i've
got a video somewhere on my instagram i
said elon what's your favorite book he
said lord of the rings and the hobbit i
said why he said because it teaches you
even though it's a fiction story
to do things even though you might fail
so it's a mindset technique
let kids sit in class and read that all
day and and run around the rest of the
day do a little jiu jitsu a little do a
boxing throw in a little applied math
how about this
let kids have an investment portfolio
it doesn't have to be real dollars but
maybe it is real dollars give all the
kids 100 bucks let them invest it in
stock market or how about cryptocurrency
now let them invest in bitcoin
and the student who does the best for
the month or the year gets a bonus make
it a fun then that's applied math
you see applied math and you start going
i want to learn how to do that i want to
learn math versus just memorize the
multiplication table nobody people don't
learn that it's not working
what did einstein say the definition of
insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results
we live i'm telling you i'm hiring high
school kids college kids i got phds at
working for me
common sense is so low i just want to
say to him get your money back
you've been conned out of this taxpayer
has been calling people going to college
they come out and i'm just like what did
you just do for four years oh i get it
you drink a lot of alcohol and party now
not to say that nobody goes through a
high school system nobody goes through
the college system and finds success of
course they do
but those people probably would have
been successful in anything because they
had great parents they had a lot of
money behind them stable families i'm
talking about the people that are
forgotten
what about the kids growing up with
single parents what about kids in the
inner city think you're gonna get them
to read siddhartha
and uh do trigonometry and calculus
for what not everybody can be engineers
some should some should learn calculus
some should learn astrophysics
but not everybody
you know what everybody needs to do how
to learn to read a book how to
self-educate so recently business
insider came out with an article talking
about the fact that apple and google no
longer require four-year degree and on
top of apple and google you got ibm bank
of america netflix and many other
companies so think about all these
universities that constantly pitch the
idea of
hey mr mrs jones the reason why you're
sending your kid to our school and
spending two hundred thousand dollars
because we have the highest percentage
of hiring people at apple google ibm b
of a that's why you put your kids
through our school because we guarantee
a good job those days have changed by
the way it's a pretty scary time right
now for universities
they are literally shivering if what i'm
about to talk to right now actually
takes place
things are going to dramatically change
with the educational system the next
decade let me get right into it point
number one speed is every single college
and university's worst nightmare things
are changing so fast right now that
everybody's worried this isn't a good
thing for universities and colleges
because universities and colleges think
about it this way
if i'm running a company if i'm running
a business if i'm google apple ibm b of
a who do you think finds out first that
things are changing faster that new
things are needed universities or
companies who do you think it finds out
first versus companies then universities
find out about it so who pivots first
they do so these companies are starting
to say why are we waiting on them to
pivot to us
while we can pivot not having to wait
for them they are slowing us down
they're not teaching the stuff we want
because they cannot catch up with the
current speed that the marketplace is
going these guys are getting killed
simply due to speed number two
memory is no longer needed there used to
be a time that everybody had that smart
uncle everybody had that smart cousin
that smart relative matter of fact what
is that show who wants to be a
millionaire wasn't one of the things was
what 50 50 all these other things and
one of them was what phone a friend
right is what it was and you would call
the uncle yes i'd like to phone a friend
who uncle john he's the smartest person
in the world you'd call uncle john uncle
john you know hey who was the 23rd
president of united states wow let me
tell you who it is this person right
that person doesn't exist a strong
memory today no longer is as important
as it used to be watch this
hey siri who was the 23rd president of
united states of america
the answer is benjamin harrison from
march 4th 1889 to march 4th 1893. you
know you know the people that are very
good at math watch this one here hey
siri what is 27 227 divided by 13
227 divided by 13 is about 17.4615
can you do it as quickly siri does it or
google oh can you do that as fast as
alexa does it what happened there see
this replaced all the people that have
great memories so you'd go to school
because oh my gosh you're going to be
able to work on this doesn't matter
anymore because these machines that by
the way all these machines that you're
talking about all of these machines are
enemies to universities today they are
enemies to universities today because
that key but no one memorization anymore
no longer that important today number
three computer science degree
is
obsolete within three years you get a
computer science degree today within
three years it's obsolete number four
teachers need to go to school not
high school graduates need to go to
school
teachers are outdated let me explain to
you why if a teacher got his or her
degree in 1988 that's an outdated degree
of 1988 number five
companies train you to specialize on a
skill set let me explain this to you
i asked one of our guys today who got an
mfa
okay it's like a phd in fine arts right
is what he got is what he told me
i asked him a question i said let me let
me ask you this
what do you remember you learned from
that school when you got your degree it
took your six or eight years what do you
remember from it he went
ah man i don't know what to take i don't
know what i remember from it i said what
did you learn from me that you still use
today honestly i don't know say
companies say they don't have time like
that because things are moving so
quickly so companies saying wait a
minute i'm waiting for you to go to
school for four years to come to me
because you're learning about drinks
bartending ecstasy drugs partying
clubbing hooking up with girls tinder
really swipe right which way do you
spell i'm waiting for you to go learn
all that stuff
that's culture you bring to my company i
don't have that kind of time i'd much
rather hire you and out of the four
years of you going to school
i'm gonna create my own programming for
you and train you in this one specific
area or two three areas that's gonna
take me
to teach you for three to six months in
current times then i'm fine i don't need
you to know all the other stuff you went
to school for that saves them time and
they're controlling what's being taught
to the students and employees that they
want very simple rather than
generalizing companies are starting to
realize we'll take charge of
specializing because we definitely
cannot wait on universities on how slow
they move next companies are starting
their own universities
very scary let me say this one more time
companies are starting their own
universities this is so scary i can't
even describe to you every college
university is going to sit there and say
what do you mean companies are starting
their own universities there's online
university we have it here ourselves
companies are starting their own
campuses
you know mcdonald's has mcdonald's
university every one of these major
companies now they have universe
universities and guess who their
professors are employees who work there
who are touching everything who are
coding everything based on today's times
not based on 20 years times based on
today's curriculum and you're going to
university at google ibm you know all
apple all of these companies and their
professors are teaching you what is
needed today an edge over all the other
universities out there last but not
least number seven you know what's
number seven very simple
these big companies by doing this
they're controlling the narrative look
things changed they are controlling what
they are brainwashing into their
employees when you go into a new school
people say brainwashing is a bad word
when you go to college what do they do
our university let me tell you what we
did we want this this person went here
that person went here and they get
brainwashed about how amazing the
university is then you become a booster
and you're going to give contributing
money for the rest of the career of that
school that's what happens right very
simple simple protocol these companies
are saying wait a minute if we're
letting these kids being brainwashed
about school why don't we brainwash them
on how great of a company we are we've
actually made an impact
we've actually made new patents we've
actually made products we've actually
created jobs
we actually changed the world here's who
we are oh my gosh i love this company
they're brainwashing early about how
special of a company they are because
they're doing the same exact thing all
these major universities doing
nationwide and rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is break the rules with adam sasik the
fact that an 18 year old or 17 year old
kid is
making the biggest decision of their
life potentially other than who they're
marrying
of taking on 50 100 000 of student debt
not knowing what they want to do with
their life is a very very tough decision
to make so
i mean you can you know maybe it's the
rockefellers who did this why do you
have to make this major major decision
in your life
when
you're 17 18 years old what are you
telling me though so maybe you take a
year off and you
just figure out what you want to do in
this world like there's no there's no
rule that says at 18 you need to go to
school you need to take on student debt
you need to graduate in four years at 22
you need to get your first advice your
advice to me is don't go to school i
would say don't play by the traditional
rules i would say if you know what you
want to be like um gary nesner he wanted
to be new at 15. i want to be an fbi
agent he knew that he wanted to do that
okay these days you can google what do i
need to do to get to be an fba agent
well you need a four-year college degree
you need to go get training
like for me when i went to college i had
no
clue what college i should go to i had
no clue what i wanted to do
um i was lucky enough to get a football
scholarship so i got all right i guess
i'm playing football now but
if i were 18 years old again i would go
get a job for a year start to make some
money you could always go back to school
when you're 19.
the question is
i think we'd all agree education is
paramount right like if you can get a
free college education free you take it
done scholarship
grants but if you're talking about
burying yourself in student loan debt
and just saying well i just kind of want
to figure it out to very
very slippery what would you say
you'd be surprised at how much you can
learn when you get rid of the idea that
the degree makes the difference think
about your school experience you
memorize a whole bunch of statistics and
random facts and figures that help you
pass a test and then 99 of it
vanishes where when you are learning
something that you know how to apply and
is directly applicable to your passion
you remember it and so that allows you
to learn really really really quickly
you either adopt a mindset why i love
this video you are either elon musk or
you are the interviewer you are either
elon musk and you approach the situation
you say i can learn anything i will be
self-taught i will figure it out i will
read books i will watch videos i will
teach myself how to do this thing or
you're like most people that interviewer
who will say yourself taught
you didn't go to school for this
and you need to decide right now what
camp you want to fall into
as long as you are in the yourself
taught
questioning not possible mindset limited
beliefs you're always going to be held
back
where if you can adopt the mindset that
i can learn anything that i want to i
can go up against experts we've been
doing this for years because i just care
more about this thing and when i
dedicate myself to something i will
learn it and be amazing at it if that's
your approach going in then guess what
you will be
i look at my instagram account as an
example
it took me a six years to get to 6 000
subscribers or six thousand fans
something like that six years right
there abouts and i just never really put
a priority on it in the past month i've
grown up by a thousand plus
so six years to get the six thousand one
month to get to seven thousand and we're
growing and we're growing we're growing
and i haven't talked about my instagram
account outside of instagram apart from
this now for those of you guys watching
i would love it if you want to follow me
on instagram my first public appeal so
i've been studying i've been spending
extra time trying to understand the
algorithm hashtag usage pictures quotes
frequency all of the things that make
instagram important understanding
stories understanding highlights
understanding how to tag within stories
and i'm teaching people on my team how
to do it i had a call the other day with
a instagram expert this is somebody who
gets paid to coach people on how to do
their instagram accounts and when i'm
talking to him
i'm talking the same language
i've only been doing this for a week at
that time but because i spent a week
immersing myself in understanding what's
happening on instagram
i can talk at the same level as somebody
who's been doing this for years
and it's not to say that i'm some
amazing genius you could do the same
thing too
you're just preventing yourself from
doing it because you think you need to
have years of experience because you
think you need to have a degree because
you think you need to go to school for
this whatever the thing is that you want
to learn
if you want to be great at it you can be
in a really really really short amount
of time if you just dedicate yourself to
it and so you need to decide
do you want to be that elon musk and
believe that you could teach yourself
anything and be a genius at it or do you
want to be the reporter and always
question everything and say you're
self-taught
it's not possible
what mindset do you want to adopt hey
mom dad i'm not going to go to a 50 000
a year school all i'm going to ask is
this if you'll continue letting me live
here let uh if you'll help me out with
my bills etc etc i'm not going to ask
you to put that money in in college and
i would say go find somebody that you
admire that you want to be like and go
intern for them for a year absolutely
free you get close to them you build
rapport uh
you know you get their contacts you do
all all this stuff like kai is a living
testimony actually guy's the man yeah of
of him him coming here and he's all the
way from norway by the way yeah from
from norway
[Music]
if you want to know if you need a
college degree to be a success check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there there's no need even
to have a college degree
at all or even high school i think a
college education is still a great
investment in yourself there's a point
of diminishing returns